[Music]
hello everyone
in the previous lecture we had derived
the formula for
finding the the deflection
uh corresponding to a point force using
the castigliano's theorem and the
specific form that we had arrived at
uh pertinent to the case of beams
so let us look at an example uh
in this lecture a very very simple
example something you are all very
familiar with
so this is the case of a cantilever beam
loaded by a point force at its tip
so the diagram is something like this
we have this beam here
and let's draw the
tip load
just like this acting vertically
downward at the
right end and of course the beam
is attached to a wall is clamped to a
wall at the
left end okay so
[Music]
maybe something like this
all right
so that represents the wall now what we
wish to find out here
is uh the deflection at this tip
and please note that when i say
deflection i specifically mean the
deflection
along the direction that this force is
pointed that is in the
vertically downward direction okay so
uh the formula that we had derived
uh in the previous class after a
after a lot of discussion uh a lot of
buildup
was this
uf bar is equal to so we can just take a
quick look
at what we had found last time
so all this discussion was regarding the
uh so regarding the material behavior we
don't need that that was
for our knowledge but this is the
formula that i'm referring to
okay so this is the the formula for the
u
the uh the strain energy uh
so we are going to use this thing okay
and uh
okay so uh
suppose this uh this force is
represented by this
p so for all intents and purposes this
is
p so this is del del p
of u and u as we had found out
as i have just shown you in from our
previous lecture
that was m square by
twice e i
d x 0 to l
please note that this entire length here
this entire length that is l
okay so
now the first question obviously and the
most important question these problems
is that
what is n so for that what we are going
to do is
uh we are first going to fix up our the
origin of our coordinate system
it is completely up to our choice so for
this kind of a cantilever problem uh
if you think about it a little bit it it
becomes very easy
if we just set up our coordinate axis at
the right end
and go leftward to account for the
for the positive direction of x so
we say that it's something like this
so this is our x now what we are going
to do
is make a cut
make a cut like this
and consider that portion of the beam
consider that portion of the beam
where of course this p is again acting
downward maybe i need to
clear up my overall picture here a
little bit
just for the sake of clarity i'll just
bring it down a little bit
okay so
what we say is that and again this is
directly following from our
undergraduate studies
that the sheer force here
the shear force here will be directed
upward
and the bending moment
is like this now it is not completely
arbitrarily
that i am drawing these conventions
there is a certain
reason and logic behind this if you are
paying attention
to what was taught in your undergraduate
days you will immediately pick up on
what i am saying
but in case some of you are not very
comfortable with this convention
and i think i may have discussed this in
our previous course on applied
elasticity also nevertheless
if you're still confused with it please
don't sweep it under
under the rug i mean
we can discuss this in one of our uh
live sessions
uh so there is a note for uh for the
students enrolled in this
in this advanced mechanics of solids
course
uh i won't invest time on this but
just to just for the record uh we all
know this from our undergraduate studies
so
m okay so this m is equal to
uh minus p
x okay so please note that what i'm
actually writing here is that
this m here this m
uh so this is m in the clockwise sense
and
the moment of this force p about
uh about an axis passing through this
end
uh where this distance of course is x
so this distance here is x
okay because we are counting from x from
the
on the right hand side we are measuring
x from the right hand side
so this is uh so the the
the moment contributed by the force p
about an axis which is passing through
this
end is px and it is in the same sense
as this m so it is actually m plus p
x is equal to zero uh and that gives us
m is equal to minus p
x okay uh but that of course doesn't
uh clarify why this should be in this
sense
okay you could you can take this in the
opposite sense it won't make any
difference to the answer but
uh but this is the convention okay and
there's a reason behind it
anyway uh you don't have to worry about
the shear force
now it is there for the force balance
now
uh we can substitute it back here to
find out our
u p bar okay so uh
our u p bar is equal to
del del p
and over here we can just substitute
this thing so it will be p
square x square by twice e
i d x
and this uh please note that
first have to write the integration
limits so this uh
del del p can be taken within this
integration so that
overall what we'll have is this
integration 0 to l
uh p x
by e i d x
because this is a square all right and
if we carry out the integration
what we'll obtain is p x cube
by 3 e i
with the proper integration limits
what we'll end up with is this very
familiar
uh answer pl cube
by 3ei so even before so just when i had
written down this uh i mean when i've
drawn this diagram
i'm sure that many of you who had done
well in gate
uh would have directly known the answer
but uh we should make a note that all of
our
sophisticated maths and uh whatever we
have been discussing the past few
lectures
it also gives us nice that that familiar
undergraduate
answer okay so this was very very easy
warm-up example uh just to show that
what we have been discussing it works
now we can go to a slightly uh
slightly more uh let's not say more
involved but
slightly different kind of problem so
simply supported being
okay and we'll try to gradually see uh
more and more involved examples okay so
again a beam but this time simply
supported
it's fixed at this end and it has a
roller here
okay so overall it is very much
statically
determinate
and the the point force
that is acting again in the vertically
downward direction
but perfectly at the midpoint here
okay so maybe this diagram is not
perfectly accurate but you get the sense
uh let me just clarify the whole thing
so from here to here
we can have this length l
and this distance
sorry about that
okay um
and of course this uh this one has
the magnitude p again right
and again we are supposed to find out
the deflection at the point of
application of this force
p ah in the same direction as this force
is
acting now
as in the previous problem our whole job
will be effectively done the moment we
we find out what is the
i mean what is the bending moment
expression
okay so what we'll do is uh
this time we are going to
consider the origin on our left hand
side
at this end with the x
in this in this rightward direction
what we are going to do is take a cut
take a cut
like this and we are going to consider
uh this left portion
the left portion of this
of this cut
the portion to the left of this cut now
please note
that now what we what we plan to do here
is to draw a free body diagram of this
little portion and when i say free body
diagram
these reactions the actual physical
reactions
they should not be appearing in its
place
the reaction from this or the reaction
force
uh reaction force or forces from this
end
that is what should be appearing now if
you were a first in mechanic student you
would start out by writing
a general horizontal direction force and
a vertical direction force and
through through force balance you would
find out that that horizontal force is
equal to zero
so i am going to skip a little bit uh
and directly consider that horizontal
pose to be zero
so this is a free body diagram with uh
with with the first year mechanics
knowledge incorporated within it
okay so uh so we have this
uh we have this reaction force here
and
[Music]
sorry about that i just redraw this
thing
okay so we have this reaction force now
uh
i'm sure that um all of you would have
figured out by now
that the magnitude of this reaction
force is going to be
p by 2.
it is going to be p by 2 because you
note that at least in the vertical
direction
this entire scenario is perfectly
symmetric
about this x equal to l by 2. so
here it is going to be the reaction
force the vertically upward reaction
force from this roller is going to be p
by 2 upward
and from this end also it is going to be
p by 2 upward so
here it is p by 2. uh furthermore
uh again going by our positivity
convention
our shear force will be like this and
our bending moment
will be in this sense okay so this is
our v and this is our
m uh and again if we
if we write the the movement balance
what we'll obtain is m
written like this so so considering this
thing this anti-clockwise sense
and if you consider the contribution to
the moment
from this p by 2 force then about an
axis passing through this end
it is going to be in the clockwise sense
so it's basically going to be
m minus t by 2 times x
where of course this distance is x
okay so it is m minus
t by 2 x is equal to 0 so that gives us
m is equal to p by 2
x that is fine
now uh specifically for this particular
case
we can note that whatever happens from x
equal to 0
to x equal to l by 2 is exactly what is
going to happen
from x equal to l to x equal to l by 2.
so exploiting this symmetry what we can
do
is uh for our for our deflection
which in general is like this
del del p of
0 to l uh it's
m square so this basic formula remains
the same for the royal beam problems
uh of course
now
what we can do here is uh is to note
that this 0 to l it can basically be
written
exploiting the symmetry of the problem
in this fashion
twice of 0 to l by 2.
all right so uh
so now if we just substitute this
expression for
m here you know that this two will
cancel with this two
so uh
what we obtain here is just this del l p
0 to l by 2 and this m
uh it becomes p square x square
by 4 e i
d x
furthermore if we actually carry out
this differentiation
we'll end up with 0 to l by 2
p x square
by twice e i
dx and
if we actually carry out the integration
we'll obtain
the x cube
6 e i
[Music]
zero to l by 2 and for our final answer
what we'll
obtain is the l cube
so this 2q will give me an 8 so an 8
times 6 is 48
so this is pl cube by 48
e i so again
i'm sure that many of you who have had a
very good
gait preparation uh these answers
uh these very special case answers uh
would be at your fingertips
and that's good but it's also good that
we know how to
obtain this formally now please note
that
i have exploited the symmetry of the the
situation here
like this but what would happen perhaps
if this
if this case was not symmetric for
instance if this
p was not situated at x equal to l by 2
instead it was situated at some general
distance
a okay so we can obtain
so we we do have a more general method
of
obtaining the answer in those cases so
what we'll do is we'll
discuss this general method uh for this
particular example
again but
uh what i will suggest is that once you
get familiar with that
with that method and uh i i suspect that
quite a few of you would already know
the method that i'm going to discuss
in any case i'll discuss it and then
perhaps uh
people who are not that much familiar
with that method they can go on to
uh to apply that that method uh to the
smooth general case
where uh p is situated not at x equal to
l by two but at x equal to a
okay uh so the method that i'm going uh
so
uh i i'm i'm talking about is uh
basically using
uh something called the singularity
function or the
or the macaulay bracket uh so basically
it's like this that suppose we do not
exploit the symmetry then what we have
to do is we have to
traverse the entire length of the beam
from x equal to zero to x equal to l
and in the process of doing that the
expression of the bending moment that is
going to change
okay because you note that from this 0
to l by 2 it is
this the this p doesn't come into the
picture this
this externally applied p doesn't come
into the picture so if
instead of taking the cut here we were
to take the cut here then
for that particular section or this
section
okay this p would very much come into
the picture and then the free body
diagram here
would look completely different okay so
what i'm saying here is this
that if i were to take this cut here
then my uh
my section would look like this
okay the reaction force here
could still very much be
p by 2 here that is not a problem
sorry
that would have been p by 2 here but but
we would also have the contribution
from this downward force
t
because now note that
this is this entire thing is our x
okay and this is this is still l by
all right so x is greater than l by 2.
so the situation is a little bit
different now
this is the same as before the same
convention but now the expression for
m will be different okay so in what
sense it will be different
it will be different because now m
would be like this
contribution from here the entire thing
but
if we have to take the contribution from
this p
it would be actually like
t into x
minus l by 2.
[Music]
so you note that x minus l by 2 is
basically this distance
and this and i'm writing this with a
plus here because
the moment of this force p
about an axis which is passing through
this end would be
in the same sense as that of this orange
colored arrow curved arrow which
represents
our m
so our m is still like this
but note that if we just write up to
this
it is not quite correct because then
that would mean
that even when i am at this distance
uh it is perhaps like this okay so so to
ensure
uh so if you can we can write it like
this with the with the understanding
that if you keep on if if we say that x
is indeed greater than l by 2
but suppose we want to write the overall
thing the overall general expression for
m so uh so how do you connect
this particular thing
and this particular thing so please note
that this is correct
for x is less than
2 so we connect connect
these two things together
by saying that m
is uh so
we write it like this m minus p by 2 x
that is not a problem this one is
like this but multiplied with the step
function or the heavy side function so
this
h please note this is the heavy side
function
which contributes like which makes the
entire term contribute
only when x is greater than l by two and
that is equal to 0
okay so uh so if we have this thing
if this kind of a term then it is
ensured that uh that
no matter where x is located the the
expression for the
m will come out as correct now this
entire thing that i have written here
that can actually be captured
by something called the singularity
function or
something more familiar uh within the
mechanics literature as a macaulay
bracket
okay so let me go to the next page
so this thing i will write as
so these angular brackets and
and conventionally we put a proper index
here which is
uh the index one that's the power one
so these angular brackets it represents
the
the macaulay bracket
okay sometimes they're also referred to
as the singularity functions
all right so uh
we can we can proceed like this we can
actually
uh actually do the integration uh
for this uh manually
uh and and i myself used to do this
thing so
i at one point in time i used to prefer
this particular thing
because i'm more familiar with the heavy
side thing but
it is very much possible to to utilize
a symbolic package like uh like the
symbolic python
within the jupyter notebook framework to
very easily calculate
these things okay so as long as we are a
little bit familiar uh
familiar with the with the terminology
and and the terms that we have to use
there
so this can very well be done so uh
so let's see uh one one example of this
uh how if you can we can actually
recover this thing
uh
[Music]
okay so i have already tested it out uh
here so we can quickly uh
use these things but let me just and let
me just demonstrate to you what
uh what is going on okay so as afresh
so uh import sim by sim
like we used to do uh in our applied
elasticity course
and uh for those of you who may be not
enrolled in this course but watching
this youtube video
uh some introductions to the jupiter
notebook
uh to the use of jupiter notebook for
these kinds of problems in solid
mechanics
we have discussed in our previous
course of applied elasticity and
and even for students who who are
enrolled in this course
if you want to revise you can take a
look at those uh introductory lectures
uh discussing the use of jupyter
notebook and especially symbolic python
uh but i am assuming that at least for
for all of you uh who are enrolled in
this course you these things would be
familiar you have already done one term
project
involved using this so it should be good
all right
so first of all we import sempi
symbolic python uh with this alias uh
uh same next uh we just set up our
variables so the things that we require
are basically uh x
uh l or the length of the beam
at the force p but uh what i'll do is
uh i'll set out this x separately
you'll realize why why in a moment so
this l and p
i know for sure that they are positive
entities
so i'll i'll i'll mention that
explicitly okay so
all right now uh what i really want to
do
is uh
is just this thing okay what we were
doing earlier
this u p bar
is equal to del del p
0 to l m square by
twice e i d x uh you can you know that
irrespective of what this uh this
m expression is involving my calling
brackets or not
uh this can be simplified
very generally as if we do the
integration
uh sorry if you do the differentiation
within the integration
sign then uh
this basically comes out as
your m
by e i
del m del p
dx okay so this is the general form uh
and i'm sure that
many of you already know this
nevertheless uh this is the form that
we're trying to
achieve here and you also know that
there isn't this e i involved
uh but i have not have not written it
here
anyway so what we would like to do is
set up our
integrand okay so uh even before that
i will uh just write this thing so
m into this so this is what we want the
differentiation
of uh of our m
with respect to p so this is this is the
form
or the integrand okay so i'm writing in
a slightly half as it fashion
but uh just to reflect my thought
process
now this m this is the key thing to
write here
so this m is equal to uh
so we take a quick look here this is
m is equal to p by 2 times x
it's p by 2 times x minus
the singularity function okay so let's
say that we use
the placeholder term sf okay please note
this sf is not defined a priori
uh like as written in sf it is not
defined like this within symbolic python
but uh
we are going to use an alias so the
important thing to note is that
this is written in the form
that uh so let me just quickly write
down here
that whenever you have this magali
bracket the way
uh python understands this
macaulay bracket is that uh
so you understand that there is an x
here so in general if you have an x
minus
a to the power sum n so what uh
but python will understand this as uh
involving this one this one and this one
so it's like a three parameter thing
okay but here of course our n is equal
to 1 our a is equal to l by 2
and x is x okay so
let's see if we can we can write this
down okay so this is
x comma l by 2
comma 1 now
sf as i mentioned is not pre
defined in this fashion however the
singularity function
just like the heavyside function is very
much defined within symbolic python so
what we'll do is
we'll we'll import it
from simp import singularity function
but use the alias
sf okay so that we are free to use what
we want to do in short
later on uh so this is
uh this is the form of our f for m
now please note that uh i'll show you
something okay i'll come to the
integration integrand
part a little bit uh so
uh so let's say that we write it like
this
okay sorry i did not press enter here
okay so suppose i want to display m
so you see this is very nicely displayed
there's no problem now what about this
integrand
what does it what does it show
[Music]
ah sorry i have to write it as sim.diff
okay so it is showing it showing us like
this
now um
suppose uh we were to actually carry out
this
uh this integration okay suppose we were
to carry out this integration from 0 to
l
so same dot integrand integrate we put
the integrand here
that is basically m times del
m del p that is what the integrand is
and the limits of x from 0 to l
okay let's just see what happens here
well
there is trouble okay
a bit problematic so
uh so when i first tried to do this
within symbolic python i also faced this
kinds of problems now uh
let's take a look at what uh
what i did to to manage this thing
so you see uh
first of all what i did here uh oh sorry
forgotten to write one thing here this
this is p
into singularity function because
as you note here this is uh
m is equal to p by 2 into x minus
p times this may call a bracket thing
okay
so let's just run this thing once more
okay so that is our thing so now you see
the integrand is a little bit more
complicated and let's now see what it
gives us
you see uh
if we don't help symbolic python
to simplify the things uh it does this
thing
in all its generality but this result is
completely unusable
okay so what we can do is to
uh is to help symbolic python
along its way what we'll do is
uh instead of keeping our m
are just like this and especially our
integrand like this
so what i did here you see that i have
uh basically rewritten this integrand
uh first of all piecewise and then
further simplified it
so this piecewise thing is something
inbuilt within symbolic python and we
can
we can import it like this uh
and the result of it is that it
basically
uh outputs the uh
this term in a form which you would
actually
write if if you if you are doing it in a
calculus fashion
with your own hand on a piece of paper
okay
so so let's try to do that we go back to
this line
[Music]
we import this piecewise utility
and then let the m remain like this
but this integrand ah
i can keep it like that this integrand
that i will rewrite
using the piecewise thing first okay so
let's just see what happens here
so it is somewhat better but not uh not
not quite so let us simplify this
further and see what happens
so this is much better and now if we do
this integration
you see it very quickly it gives us the
nice answer uh
pl cube by 48 of course i have not
written this
ei earlier that i can can quickly write
down here
a problem so this e young's modulus the
second moment of area
e i all of them are positive entities no
problem there
so i'll keep this thing like this
the integrand however i'll just
multiply by 1 by e i
sorry eight times i
i didn't run this i think
[Music]
all right now it should give me the
correct answer
that's it all right so uh
because i have discussed so much in it
it may seem like a
like a lot of steps and i've also broken
down the steps
here but in all you can see that when i
and i wrote it here it was quite short
okay so
uh for more complicated examples
and especially when you don't have the
luxury of this uh this actually
symmetric thing
now then uh you will have a uh
another parameter like a uh
so what i'm saying here is that if you
if you go back to this
to this diagram and instead of
this this p located at
l by 2 suppose it were located at some
distance x equal to a
then uh carry i mean carrying out this
integration by hand
would be quite involved and then you
will
really reap the benefits of using this
symbolic python here okay so on that
note
uh i will end this video uh thank you
very much and i hope you
uh you get to explore this on your own
furthermore